nitrous does not make you go light speed
from star wars
oh my god dude the cameraman at that
point gear shifter i told you
every single movie aim for the baby
we'll get the shot
thanks to raycon for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to find
out how you can get 15
off your order of everyday e25s what's
up everybody welcome back
actually it's the first episode of stunt
drivers react
and we got david patterson here today to
break down
some common mistakes that directors make
in car chases and also to shed some
light on some of the intricacies that i
didn't know about
the [ __ ] man i know about that you guys
well i can't say definitely
but dave is here to drop all the
information on you guys i'm super
excited for this episode
david can you tell the audience a little
bit about yourself yeah sure i've been
doing youtube for
over 10 years now i've driven over 1200
cars
and know a lot about the ins and outs of
how cars work and how they drive
specifically
and a huge history buff when it comes to
car stuff directors make
a lot of weird decisions so it's
interesting when you can tell when they
use phrases or terminology that makes
absolutely no sense but the audience
just needs to
get it so it's fun to break that down so
let's kick it into 12th gear and hit the
nitro boosters
and jump on in is that right it's fast
and furious right
all right okay sweet all right so we're
going to kick things off the fast and
the furious right that's right
the first race in fast and furious ever
it's the most made fun of car scene in
any movie ever according like to car
culture it's like an inside joke it's
that bad
is that ludicrous is he in the first jaw
rule find y'all rule get hold of this
house
cause i can make sense of all this where
is
job get it right dude i mean he really
went places with fire festivals
you'll notice they're using low profile
tires on these big wheels because they
look flashy they would not get any
traction whatsoever it's the worst
wheel and tire setup so what's a low
profile tire bigger wheel
less tire that's in a nutshell typically
when you're doing drag racing like
they're doing here
you would want a drag slick or a radial
which is just like pure tread
it's terrible in the rain and it can't
turn but it can put all the power down
to the ground
nitrous in this movie is so exaggerated
too so like
nitrous does not make you go light speed
from star wars
so all that happens in real life is the
car goes a little bit faster
action movies are the issue where they
never reload guns your movies have the
issue where they're always changing
gears right you'll notice it in
almost every car chase though they'll
keep showing him shift i'm like okay
like you're in gear
it's okay you're in gear that's so funny
danger to man danger to manifold what's
a manifold honestly
according to this movie i don't know
because i think they just
found some words that worked and maybe
the audience will kind of get that
something's going wrong but your
computer would not be like hey guess
what this is going wrong
the reason it confuses everybody is
because after this moment
his floorboard falls out for no reason
yeah look random that makes no
sense
the late 90s and early 2000s it was an
absolute explosion
when it came to japanese tuner cars
because technology had finally
caught up to where if you built one of
these cars right you could beat a v8 car
are these v4 cars so they're inline four
typically
so they're just four cylinders in a row
but then people would throw a big
turbocharger on them and then
force them to make power you can make a
thousand horsepower out of those four
cylinders
[Music]
is there an example where the cars that
they're using
are legit and you can tell on camera
yeah the most plausible example in the
first fast and furious is
dom's charger versus the toyota supra
the orange hero car but only thing is
dom would absolutely annihilate the
supra because for one reason
[Music]
if you look at his rear tire dom is
basically more on like a drag setup and
then
here's brian still on hot boy wheels
that super supposed to make like 550
horsepower
and then the dodge is supposed to make
like 900. so
it wouldn't even be a race
is that possible that's a hundred
percent possible really in that car
in that car yeah i'm pretty sure they
used movie magic for this moment
if you ever go to a local drag strip
you'll see cars popping wheelies
right off the line here's the thing
though you can't steer you don't have
any traction in the front wheel so
you better be going straight
oh man the most underrated car chase i
think
ever filmed this is where a lot of the
car community started getting
disconnected
to fast and furious because it's more
like a heist film and spy film
i personally love fast five out of all
the more heist ones
because the driving is so real
interesting thing about the vault it's
real so it's a 9
000 pound vault that they put plastic
under it to get it to slide but the only
problem was they couldn't get it to stop
so it would get all this momentum and
just go by you'll eventually see that
there's sparks coming out the bottom
that's because they're
actually dragging it
oh my god dude the cameraman at that
point
this bank building was actually built
for the movie oh really
and they just decided to full send it
and actually destroy it that's some
meemaw tank stuff right there
i actually heard for that for some
scenes the vault was actually placed on
top of a car
yeah so they had either the real vault
which was like 9 000 pounds then they
had a pickup truck
if there was a shot that just was deemed
too much to pull it
they put the vault on top of it then the
other one was a semi truck and they
fully built a vault like around the
front of a semi truck
[Music]
the biggest thing about this scene is
the actual driving
because these two stunt drivers have to
be quite literally perfect because they
both have to have that tension on that
cable
[Music]
he has to do a j turn
it's hard enough doing that on your own
but let it off pulling a vault
you know
so videos these days are measured on a
satisfaction metric
you want to know what really makes that
tick well it's subscriptions so if
you're not subscribed and you feel like
subscribing
you'll help our satisfaction metric out
it'll be cool thank you because here at
corridor digital
satisfaction is guaranteed
[Music]
bullet was such a big influence because
they're doing stuff with cars
in a film that pretty much nobody had
done before
steve mcqueen believed in order to do it
he actually went to a racetrack
and practiced with the other driver
getting close at high speed to get them
comfortable
and then they just wing it
i think a lot of people saw this and
they said oh so we don't have to fake
everything we get people who actually
know how to drive
and just rent out the road they need and
do it it also made it
feel more visceral
uh close call oh oh wait was that a
dirty hit the car
it looked like he hit the car or was
that it does look like he hit the car he
definitely did
him being gone that's a bad jump cut oh
my god yeah they just got to not being
there because it probably hits the
camera in the very next frame just add a
bubble
sound effect it's gone yeah yeah
dang they are brunching it's funny
because it doesn't actually look like
you're going super fast but just the
hills
and turns are so much more exhilarating
[Music]
this catching air though like look at
this yeah sketch
i always want to try getting air in a
car
so that rear projection action oh yeah
for sure back in the day they didn't
have green screen so they just projected
film onto the screen behind you
basically what they do with the
mandalorian now what's old is new
these aren't rear projection shots here
this is legit that's so dangerous
oh wow yep boom right into like a
propane or gas station why do you store
the explosive barrels in the parking lot
yeah i know
you want to take a ride there fat man
anybody want to milk shake doyle is bad
news
but he's a good cop this film is called
the french connection
and it had extremely loose permits
what do you mean by that the director
wanted to film it more like a
documentary
so all these poor souls walking on the
street are actual new yorkers
they're just minding their own business
so it didn't even close the roads nope
that's so dumb you're so risky it's so
risky
why money some people die
[Music]
is that gene heckman it is gene hackman
yeah genius scoundrel yeah the director
didn't tell the crew or anything
what to expect they just said basically
show up i'd be so pissed
this is such like a video game mission
it really is it's like a gta mission
this is where things get really intense
[Music]
near miss but doesn't miss i don't
understand so that truck was not
so i can't confirm it but i'm pretty
sure it was just a pedestrian truck and
they paid for everything
afterwards with all the crashes
[Music]
probably the only extra in the whole
thing aim for the baby we'll get the
shots
[Music]
it's a hard stop dude that's how i pull
up the trader joe's
[Laughter]
that's crazy yeah the back story of it
is where the crazy part is
and the driving is legitimately crazy
dude
no never bad director bad bad he's in
the 70s
all good things come to those who wait
so this is ronin and ronan is known for
having one of the
best car chases in film now in this day
and age i don't know if it holds up so
let's take a look and just
see what you think you know i'll see if
a smile creeps across your face
there's something about a chase in a
tunnel yeah they always look good just
get that warp speed feeling you know
yeah yeah it's a lot faster because
things are closer look at the stress on
robert de niro's face
oh yeah just casually do some damage to
your tunnel knock the tiles off the wall
that's what i'm saying like they have to
pay for all that right they must
[Music]
i like how they're flushing their lights
actually because believe it or not if
you go to germany
if you're on the left lane the autobahn
which is the fast lane and you see
somebody way in the distance and you're
catching them you just flush your lights
and they move right on over wow just
like that
and it's not like a dick move no no
that's cool that's chill i like that
[Applause]
there it is gear shifter i told you
every single movie
is he downshifting he is downshifting
but the little wiggle is kind of weird
instead of just going for the gear he's
[Applause]
like
oh wow damn that guy got messed up
that is so precise hit the back tire and
not
hit the guy's leg this is more visceral
than any motorcycle hit from gemini man
do you mean a man jam i nigh man
[Music]
i love i love when car chases go through
like corridors and the first italian job
they do that in like a shopping mall or
subway or something like that
and then in the more modern one they go
through like a sewer tunnel or something
but it always makes it look
way faster
you know what's crazy we didn't even
register what about the camera we take
it for granted as these guys are dodging
cars but the camera car is also dodging
cars left and right
[Music]
that wouldn't damp
why was the pinto exploding why is it
the butt of this joke
basically the way it was engineered it
had a lot of the parts in the back
including the fuel tank that's why when
you saw cars getting hit and catching on
fire
[Applause]
[Music]
that's why the pinto was a joke for
decades now and it is a dangerous car to
drive
i do not recommend it but yeah that
wouldn't happen
that would not happen they poured
gasoline or something in there to make
that happen
so every time we asked for comments we
asked for like a different thing like
car stunts or you know martial arts or
whatever
i want to see some bad stunts that's
right i don't mean bad it's like they
got messed up i don't see bad isn't like
it looks hokey
it's clearly a different person give me
the jankiest
or stunts because you know what this
series is after all called something
react too bad and great stunts and we
need some bad stunts to look at all
right what do we got next
i actually have not seen this movie it's
the most hipster car movie ever
they marketed this movie more like a
fast and furious like trailer like
this is drive he's running away and then
you watch the movie and i remember
people
screaming the theater going boring
this is probably the most accurate
depiction of somebody
outrunning the police so most of the
time when you see a car chase let's say
on the news and you see that guy that's
on the highway running he's not going to
get away
but this character is smart about it and
only uses his driver skill when he
absolutely has to
and when he knows that he can out handle
the police chasing him
[Music]
so he's listening to a police scanner
and they go hey we think
it might be a silver impala but look he
sees cops he hides he doesn't make it
blatantly obvious
that he's the bad guy
it's insane i know exactly where this is
yeah this is like down the street this
is weird
this is literally like two blocks away
that sixth tree right there it's been
torn down so we filmed nerf team
fortress right there oh no way
so right here he sees the cop come up
and he's like does he know who i am
and then when the light turns green he
doesn't just run the red light right he
waits for it to turn green like a normal
person
and then notices the cop knows it's him
and he goes for it oh man that is so
intense
that's great yeah it's really well done
there's some good filmmaking right there
so i'm just a little vfx artist
filmmaker
and i spend all my time here just on
computers or polka dot cameras but you
might remember
this one video we made back in the day
where eric linden took clinton here
and lit him on fire and i've been really
jealous
ever since it's true so when david came
out he was like hey would it be cool
if i got a couple my stunt driver
friends together in a track and taught
you and sam how to stunt drive
and i was like yes that would be cool
that video is out
on the channel right now so go check it
out there's a link in the description
below
probably here on the end card as
that's well be us i think maybe
[Music]
what's up y'all hey i hope you guys
enjoyed this episode it was made
possible by
raycon our sponsor today they have a
line of earbuds called the everyday
e25s and i want to tell you guys a
little bit about them so the everyday
e25
earbuds are super stylish they're very
comfortable on the ears and the sound
quality is top-notch
they're actually very affordable
compared to other earbud lines and they
have a variety of colors so no matter
what your style they got something for
you they come in a compact carrying case
that can charge the earbuds four times
on a single charge they got you guys
with six
hours of play time seamless bluetooth
pairing
and these earbuds are great for working
from home working out listening to music
and podcasts
for hours so if you guys are interested
in your own pair of raycon earbuds
go to buyrecon.com corridor crew to get
off your purchase they've been really
kind to us so go ahead and check them
out
see you guys next time peace david you
just filled my head
with amazing information information
that hopefully will help me out on the
road when it comes time to you know
maybe dodge a rain puddle or something
but dude thank you so much for coming
out it was really cool if you guys want
to check out
david's channel he actually has a
youtube channel that dude in blue if you
guys are into cars
maybe if you're not even into cars you
will be after you go to david's channel
that dude in blue
check it out it's going to be a fun time
to promise but david thanks for joining
us man
good times